hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday April 17th 2017 what's going on
how are ya happy Patriots Day everybody
um I believe that only know my voice
right now I believe that uh
Massachusetts is kind of the only place
that takes Patriots Day Off kind of sort
of you know they have the Boston
Marathon right they usually play a Red
Sox game during the day for everybody
doesn't want to [ __ ] run around and
watch a bunch of skinny people running
down the damn street [ __ ] themselves
on hat break hill every year somebody
shifts themselves in that race you know
that any time there's a marathon there's
people that push themselves so hard that
they literally [ __ ] themselves
they [ __ ] running up the hill you
know those runners they wear those
little [ __ ] nylon shorts and stuff so
there's nowhere for it to go and these
maniacs they just stay just keep running
with [ __ ] going down the back of their
legs like one of those [ __ ] horses
they carry you know drags the newlyweds
around the park you know but even then
you know they put the tail up they
[ __ ] shoot it out always going in
early with the [ __ ] jokes everybody's
this what it's gonna be
is it literally gonna be whose [ __ ] show
um yeah so whatever happy Patriots Day
to everybody I don't even know what
Patriots Day is you know I don't think
it's about the football team because
it's not football season assistant when
we raise the banner Patriots Day let's
look it up shall we people Patriots day
hash tag what the [ __ ] is it why does it
automatically go to [ __ ] Wikipedia
even though I would have gone here all
right there's a patriot day of film
starring mark Mark Wahlberg that's not
what I was looking for hey [ __ ]
[ __ ] I just don't understand I
had oh my god I had the worst day with
my [ __ ] phone like yesterday I tried
to update it you know and then it comes
back on and then you need all your
[ __ ] passwords and no matter how much
I type them in
way they're supposed to be it doesn't
recognize it then it shuts down my phone
then it's going a la Bonjour guten tag
and like 50 different [ __ ] languages
and I can't I can't
I came so if I had not I have meditated
in a month I'm not gonna lie to you but
I if I hadn't meditated so much the
beginning part of year I would have
broke my phone in half I grabbed I
turned it sideways and I [ __ ] started
I started to do it I started the [ __ ]
break it and I stopped I did throw it at
the couch into the cushions and I also
did throw my laptop into they were all
into the cushions not overly high you
know it's funny when I lifted up the
laptop I felt the pain of my rotator
cuff so I could only throw it so hard it
was really pathetic it was a very
pathetic display of anger so you know I
don't know my phone still [ __ ] with
me you know I'm trying to go into the
goddamn Apple store here and they won't
let me do it I don't understand you know
Apple is it everybody [ __ ] loves his
country you know can somebody please
[ __ ] explain to me why they're so
hostile when it comes to any sort of
customer support is there [ __ ] reason
there's not a phone number I can't talk
to anybody they're like [ __ ] you here's
our product that doesn't work go [ __ ]
yourself we're not responsible for
anything you don't know what we look
like you don't know where we are don't
even talk to me about those [ __ ]
Apple stores with the people walking
around with the genius t-shirts give me
a [ __ ] break
that sound says somebody just came into
my house I hear it all the time so I
mean doesn't mean [ __ ] to me um anyways
what that was like an anger meter you
know as I was getting up higher would
ring and they would let me know to come
back down again you know like an idiot
light on some car that your engine's
overheating
anyways [ __ ] those Apple stores - all
right those are dead it's all [ __ ]
you're talking to low-level people in
the in the company nobody who's [ __ ]
designing these goddamn things that end
up being [ __ ] up is working at that
store you give that stupid [ __ ] shirt
that says genius it should say peon
um and then what do they got to deal
with [ __ ] balding hotheads like me
who come walking in going like dude
where the [ __ ] did all my music go what
did you put it on the cloud I don't want
you to have my stuff fine I don't you
know I shouldn't never stopped getting
CDs all I know is everything's [ __ ] up
okay so now I'm signing in the [ __ ] on
my laptop my phones talking to me going
hey somebody signing in on another
device and there's no place for me to
say yeah I know it's me and then the
laptops doing the same thing that
they're like it's like David Lee Roth
and Eddie Van Halen it's like you guys
you were great together we had the band
and now you [ __ ] breaking up and
you're talking [ __ ] about each other and
don't even talk to me about those
[ __ ] numbers I'm supposed to punch in
because I did that too I went into my
settings
I [ __ ] hit the stupid uh whatever
clicked on my name went into passwords
type the [ __ ] number that they just
sent me into the thing and they said
they didn't recognize it and then they
freeze up my phone freeze up my phone
like I'm working in the Pentagon or
something
look I'm some [ __ ] general I'm just
some jerk-off who once listen to some
[ __ ] hair metal from the 80s KK you
know well I get on a treadmill it's all
I'm trying to do here you know what it
is it's it's [ __ ] it's incestuous you
know how really rich people want to keep
the money in their family you know so
they just sort of a sort of breed with
the same Five Families
I've talked you this before so it's why
you know you look at the Kennedys it's
like they're good-looking from the
forehead down to like the mouth area and
then they smile and it's whoa you know
stouts look like they should be playing
a [ __ ] banjo you know so it's the
same thing with technology technology
used to be a radio was radio over
there's my stereo that over there is the
dishwasher right slash made um sorry
just thinking about the time I was
talking about and then you had your walk
winds right then the Walkman also had a
[ __ ] radio and a phone was a phone
and now they've all four they've all
just been gay
banging right this big [ __ ] Caligula
[ __ ] fisting technological I don't
know what they're all the same goddamn
thing now everything everything is just
on those [ __ ] things and I I don't
know it's ridiculous so what I ended up
doing I sure I I started to like it was
weird like I had the strength signals
sent from all the way to like my wrists
I didn't let it get to my hands I felt
the anger go like like the Hulk right
the [ __ ] my arms turned green all the
way down to my wrists and I just I stop
myself from breaking it in half but I
have to tell God that would have been
such a great feeling to just snap there
has to be YouTube videos of people
snapping the [ __ ] phones in half um
what I did was I just said [ __ ] that
phone [ __ ] the laptop and I had a drum
lesson and I got in my truck and I just
[ __ ] drove over any I can admit you
know what was kind of [ __ ] nice not
having a phone you know I wasn't looking
at text messages while driving I wasn't
doing any that type of [ __ ] trying to
[ __ ] scroll to the next goddamn song
none of that [ __ ]
I just was I don't know driving a car
like I used to talking to myself and
then I came back calm down I tried it
again and about I don't know maybe the
17th attempt I got it to work again and
I just got it as you know as great as
these are and my ability to communicate
with you guys and everything like that
you know I I still would have been
alright
without these things I could have made
it the old-fashioned way as a comedian
where you just keep doing the clubs and
doing the club's then I do a guest spot
on the Hollywood Squares right next to
Paul Lynde you know maybe do a [ __ ]
Tonight Show then I just keep building
him I could have made it that way
I didn't need all of this [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] that these [ __ ] Yolo douches you
know selfies and then the picture you
take that it takes sort of a video but
it's a picture but it's also a video you
know these flying squirrel suits I mean
I don't know
what is it you just have to do [ __ ] that
other people didn't do is that what it
is
Madame [ __ ] you know back in the day
you know what it was back in the day
you [ __ ] did the clubs until you
built up enough of the following on your
own that you headlined clubs and then
maybe you got an hour special then you
know now if you're a middle act you need
an hour special to headline like the
whole thing is - I just feel like this
old man like what's the deal of
everything alright Patriots Day
everybody
Patriots day where is it Patriots day in
Massachusetts in Wisconsin and Patriots
day in Maine is an official state
holiday commemorating the anniversary of
the battles of Lexington and Concord
well what the [ __ ] does Maine and
Wisconsin have to do with that
the first battles of the American
Revolution or just his Maine and
Wisconsin the only other two [ __ ]
states of respect our holiday the
holiday was originally celebrated on
April 19th the actual anniversary of the
battles fought in 1775 since 1969 has
been observed on the third Monday in
April in Massachusetts and in May Dolan
get a three-day weekend out of it you
know [ __ ] the 19 just make sure it's on
a Monday it's also the first day of a
vacation week for public schools in both
states in both states and a school
holiday for many local colleges and
universities both public and private the
day is a public school observance day in
Wisconsin Florida law also encourages
people to celebrate it like those
[ __ ] people needed an encouragement
to celebrate anything else if I can
celebrate like every day's Patriots day
[ __ ] meth day though it is not
treated as a public holiday observing
PSA's and reenactments of battle
occur occur I'm ever going to one of
those when I was a kid I thought those
people were [ __ ] [ __ ] shooting the
guns and pretending to die and all that
stuff I thought it was awesome then I
got older and I was like yeah I mean if
that's what he's into
alright the Boston Marathon is run on
Patriots Day every [ __ ] year
therefore sometimes the holiday is
referred to as Marathon Monday the
Boston Red Sox have been scheduled have
been scheduled to play at home and
family Park and Patriots Day every year
since 1959 the games are postponed due
to weather in 59 61 65 67 and 84th do I
need all of this alright we got it okay
we got it so that's what it is it's
commemorating the first battles of the
American revolutions in Lexington and
Concord
I thought Gettysburg was the first one
that wasn't the first one oh that was a
civil war oh my god shaking my head
shut up you [ __ ] Wikipedia readin
[ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] about your war
knowledge did you fight in it well then
shut up
alright you know it's funny before it
came in here right I was watching the
Celtics lose it's a fresh loss of time
I'm taping this Sunday night Celtics
lost to a giant Jamie Foxx and the
Chicago Bulls
dude that Butler guy looks like Jamie
Foxx circa like somewhere in the 90s in
living color and uh you know [ __ ]
brutal game brutal game brutal game but
it was also you know with Isaiah losing
his sister and stuff it was kind of like
the drama of the game was definitely
just looked at us it's a [ __ ] game
look what this guy's going through but
the Bulls as much as they're an
eight-seat you know let's go a little
sports morning talk radio day you don't
leave Chicago Bulls he's punched Aaron a
seat there you have a lot of veteran
presence and getting experience oh we
wish you're Dwyane Wade with your
wherever I go and yeah it's not gonna be
an easy one um and then they got that
Unabomber guy like I don't know what the
[ __ ] that guy's deal is
you know what I mean I think when I look
at that guy his due
the hair Joey has in the [ __ ] facial
hair I just hear his agent you know
going like dude we've tried everything
to get you a lucrative advertising
contract we got nothing so I you know
why don't you just be the crazy [ __ ]
hair and bearded face guy why don't we
try that did the Birdman retire yet you
know I see a cluster phobic looking at
that guy's [ __ ] tattoos they just kept
going higher and higher like the lily
would choking him
very colorful very Marvel comic yes we
lost whatever man [ __ ] in one game you
know what are you gonna do I mean we
live and die but we got one guy we got
[ __ ] Isiah Thomas that's our guy okay
he's the [ __ ] guy we live and die by
the threes we don't get [ __ ] offensive
boards and I thought you can get away
with that in the regular season we come
playoff time you know you might get
exposed that's what I'm worried about
and the Bruins blew it you blew it we
[ __ ] blew game we blew it we [ __ ]
blew it
Game two I think we forgot that there
was a third period we were all impressed
with ourselves you know we scored three
goals in the second period or something
like that or two something we went up
three gate we have 3 to 1 up 3 to 1
everything's going good and the
cross-check in [ __ ] that are the Ottawa
Senators Jesus Christ
if one Ottawa Senators bitched about the
refereeing in that game I saw one play
like this [ __ ] guy he cross-checked
the same guy twice right in front of the
net the guy went down twice no call it
was like every [ __ ] third cross-check
that they would call and then that that
color commentator was so Pro odda what
was [ __ ] ridiculous that that first
one he was trying to say that that you
know the goal was offsides it's I kind
of [ __ ] you tell that he definitely
seems like he moves his leg but there's
no way you can see from that shitty
angle from nine I love the NHL too it's
like they're gonna they're gonna
implement [ __ ] replay but then for
whatever reason they're gonna have a
camera on top of the goddamn arena at
least that's the feet we got it's like
how the [ __ ] can you tell what the guys
on
or not I don't know might have been a
good call might have been a bad call I
had no idea what the color commentator
was convinced that's a doubt that they
should I think they should have called
that went back I'll [ __ ] you just go
skate down the goddamn river and go get
you [ __ ] whatever whatever whatever
the [ __ ] you guys eat up there um so
anyways we'll see how that one goes
I'm hoping uh I'm both basically open
the same thing for the Bruins and the
Celtics I know we're not went in the
championship and either [ __ ] League
I'm just hoping we can go as far as we
can all right get some good playoff
experience and build on that that's what
the [ __ ] I'm looking for that's it
that's all nothing crazy you know I
didn't even look to see if I know the
Predators they won that first game one
to nothing a pitcher's duel see well see
what the [ __ ] happened with them in Game
two I know the [ __ ] ranges and the
[ __ ] Canadians were playing what do
we got here what's going on what's going
on the world the NHL [ __ ] penguins
they're the team to beat man [ __ ] the
Capitals till the Capitals do something
ah you [ __ ] the Canadiens won again
god I hate those [ __ ] bastards
they're not gonna win [ __ ] though blues
take a three games to none series over
the wild what else do we got here what's
going on with the folk come on me can
you just give me the [ __ ] scores here
Oh Pittsburgh wins in overtime
all right well where's the rest of the
where's the rest of this course what
happened yesterday Chicago when should
it be this difficult should you just go
on the website it's just all right there
for mouth-breathing morons like me is
this asking too much I went the wrong
way
Nashville won five to nothing oh my god
Anaheim's up two games to none
Nashville's up two games to none Toronto
beat Washington in overtime huh I wonder
I didn't hear from [ __ ] Josh Adam
Maya's we lost in overtime
alright let's [ __ ] this page I don't
want to go back and relive this [ __ ]
[Music]
so yeah that's what I did today that's
what I've been doing this weekend
hanging out with my daughter and I'm
just watching playoffs I watched that
[ __ ] f1 race in Bahrain whenever the
hell that one was at I actually taped at
this time I had a great time watching
that the Ferraris went again when again
what's-his-face wanted I didn't write
down his name one of those V guys wanted
you know Hamilton got [ __ ] penalized
five seconds for driving too slow
slowing up Ricardo and then people were
going like hey you know I don't think he
should have been I don't think he should
have been penalized for the [ __ ]
basically what was happening was
Mercedes was pitting both their cars at
the same [ __ ] time you know so the
other guys in there the guy was not Nico
Rosberg he's in there
that botas guy right he's [ __ ]
sitting there it's basically it's like
when the jet pulls into the airport you
know and then you're all excited you're
20 minutes [ __ ] early but then the
guy gets under kept speaking at so you
can see we arrived about 11 minutes
early unfortunately our gate is still
occupied so why well he doesn't make a
difference if we get here early or not
we're still gonna pull up to the jet way
at the same time so Wow
just sit back lag Liam's workplace
you're gonna wear what you know enjoy
the tarmac right same [ __ ] thing
Oh KC's [ __ ] guy sorry I don't want
to wait too long I was just trying to
member the names of the airport [ __ ]
right so there's the other guys I
already sitting there all right that
Boutros boutros-ghali guys already
[ __ ] sitting there so he's pulling
into the pits he knows he can't go there
so he starts slowing the [ __ ] down you
know causing the other [ __ ] guy
Ricardo his spots open it's like do get
the [ __ ] out of the way you know at
least that's the way the official saw it
but I actually agree with the officials
because Lewis Hamilton is uh is is I you
know I haven't watched too much but I
think he's he's like that level
competitive well he will pull like
little [ __ ] he moves like that and I
think that that's why he got penalized
you know because you know it's like it's
like when marShon get busted with the
[ __ ] you know the stick to the balls
you don't I mean you're gonna get
suspended because anyway we know we know
we know the other [ __ ] you done so I
think Lewis Hamilton gets the same
[ __ ] treatment anyways
congratulations to Sebastian Vettel and
the Ferrari team this has been great
three races Ferrari wins one Mercedes
wins the other now Ferrari wins the
third one I like it's gonna be nice back
and forth Sebastian Vettel leads [ __ ]
Lewis Hamilton by seven championship
points 68 to 61 telling you guys get
into it's like 57 laps it's a great
[ __ ] time go see what the Illuminati
does with their money it's a phenomenal
goddamn sport it's already way better
than last year where was just [ __ ]
the Mercedes it was a race to the first
turn and then that was it was over been
very very happy with it this year um so
anyways um what else did I do this
weekend I've been working out like a
[ __ ] maniac I actually got on the
scale said 174 you know I got some
acting work this week I'd like to be
about a buck 72 you know that's the way
I kind of need to be around so I don't
look like a big-headed [ __ ] jackass
you know shoutout to all you actresses
out there who think only women deal with
that it's so hard shut up shut up you're
in a movie shut up a second obviously I
got I can't be too loud my daughter's
sleeping but my wife was watching that
Keeping Up with the Kardashians and they
were having a tough moment in their
family you know and they were all
sitting there soon you know I just it
just seems like it's one thing after
another and I know a lot of families
deal with that but just it's been really
[ __ ] it's been really hard and as
they're saying this they're sitting in a
private jet being filmed for a
television show on their way to New York
City and they're all said that with
these sad pound puppy looks on their
faces I don't give a [ __ ] if I was going
to my own funeral if I was on a private
jet to [ __ ] in New York City I would be
getting shit-faced the pilots would love
me you know I would never disrupt what
they're doing up there I would be like
I'm [ __ ]
guys right sitting there all sad it's
just hard because you know with
everything that happened last year to
then come into this year and have more
hard things to be happening it's just
really hard I would love to take that
clip you know and show it to people who
actually really have problems do a
reaction video you know whoever sewed
together their [ __ ] clothes and I'm
guilty of it to everything I [ __ ]
wear is made in a sweatshop I actually
tried one time there was a there was a
website called no sweat I don't know if
it still exists and they made all these
clothes none of it was sweatshop labor
and I looked at all the clothes and none
of it was cool clothes and I was like
wow I want to do the right thing but I
can't wear that [ __ ] all my friends are
going to make fun of me so I put my own
insecurity ahead of [ __ ] people
working for sweatshop labor prices I
don't know I just know it's just really
hard sometimes even if you are in a
private chat on your way to New York
City drinking champagne they wouldn't
bring a champagne they were just sitting
there looking sad with their big [ __ ]
Brown Kardashian eyes you know what they
look like one of those [ __ ] creepy
paintings you know they make a kids with
remember that bet artists that just had
those giant [ __ ] eyes that was like
his thing they had giant these giant
[ __ ] creepy eyes I gotta look this
[ __ ] up there this guy this guy actually
made a ton of money they were considered
cute in like the 70s and I always
[ __ ] hated them always hated him oh
by the way if you're wondering how the
point system works in f1 you get 25
points if you come in first and you get
points all the way down to tenth place
it goes 25 like 15 12 10 8 6 4 2 1 I
believe that's how it goes oh and then
everybody else can go [ __ ] themselves
by the way how funny was it in that guy
driving for the Honda's just bitching
over the radio about what a piece of
[ __ ] his car was he sounded like me in
high school except he's driving a
[ __ ] Formula One racecar he said this
is the most underpowered race car I've
ever driven in my life they're all
sitting like guy do
not on the radio and then they cut into
his car and it says Honda on the side of
it anyways uh it was a really
fascinating race because they were
somewhere in the Middle East and there
was they were worried about sand blowing
onto the track which could chew up the
tires and obviously [ __ ] with the
traction I don't know the more I get
into it the more I like it what the [ __ ]
was I looking at like a creepy big eyed
kids paintings 70s this is how I search
for [ __ ] I better get it I've got to get
it come on
the big eyed children the extraordinary
of an epic art fraud no that's not them
what is every art gallery have let that
older white woman with the really short
hair like a boys haircut but it's like
stylized you know like she sings in
oasis or some [ __ ] vintage oh there it
is is this it no that's not them I guess
everybody does the big eyed thing what
the big eyes what the [ __ ] was that
think all wasn't called like love is
that's not it Wow a lot of people with
the big eyed kids a big eyed kids in you
[ __ ] big eye kid love is dot dot dot
big eyes let's see if that works all
right I give up
I [ __ ] give up now to show me a
picture of Spongebob Squarepants
freaking out on some drugs do you guys
know the ones I was talking about they
have little bodies they had giant heads
and these big [ __ ] eyes these little
pink [ __ ] arms and [ __ ] they just
were they were creepy as [ __ ] and
everybody thought they was so goddamn
cute I was a dumb kid though do you know
what every time I walked into a photo
shop back then and they'd have picture
frames and then they've already have
like a picture in it like I thought like
you'll buy in that picture
my mother one time I was looking at
picture frames I was like why would you
want that one I mean whose kids are
those she just laughed she's laughed
when she could no you take it out and
you put your picture in there I was like
oh now that I have a kid I can't imagine
like that's got to be a terrifying
moment like oh my god is my kid gonna be
homeless
how [ __ ] you know come home you look
at you like that dead dumbness was not
in me you know you come home you look at
your spouse that's you you did that
that's your strand of [ __ ] DNA
messing up my 50% thank you very much
all right let me be a little bit
advertising here for the week that's
gonna drive me nuts big eyed [ __ ]
kids all right
wink when you have a great glass of wine
it enhances the moment
yeah it's called getting shit-faced
whether you're reflecting on the day or
with someone you love wink understands
this it's why one they started their
company to give you access to
exceptional wines from around the world
so you have more of those moments I just
picture them smash cutting people
shit-faced yelling at their kids I said
go to bed just go to try wink winc calm
spelled T ry winc dot-com whiskey India
November charlie calm take a brief
pallet profile quiz and wink will
recommend distinct and interesting wines
actually customized to your palate to be
shipped directly to your door every
month why do people drink wine think
they're so [ __ ] smart customized for
your palate you get in shit-faced you're
drinking like a pirate none of your time
is wasted fitting and fitting in a run
to the store or on your way home from
work or on your way to invent or a
gathering no more time spent guessing
what you might like because wink bases
the wines they send you on your taste
preferences wink will even introduce you
to new rare
and custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you the story
behind each one now here's a story in
this one it's not approved by the FDA
and somebody made in the sink all right
but it gave will get you [ __ ]
champagne join for free skip any month
canceling time and they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee so you
never pay for a bottle you don't like
and right now wink is offering listeners
$20 off your first order when you go to
try wink calm / / they'll even cover the
cost of shipping
that's tri wink spelled T ry winc comm /
/ to get $20 off your first order now
plus complimentary shipping try that's
try wink calm / / now you realize the
loophole in there is that if you're not
on a percent satisfied you never have to
pay for a bottle you don't like so what
you do is you order like ten bottles
okay you take a glass from each one bi
GAD and like that didn't like that one
either get to the tenth one yeah all
these bottles suck give me ten more all
right I am not 100% satisfied all right
me undies oh boo doo doo me undies me
undies drinking your [ __ ] wine - doo
doo doo me undies me undies it's nice
and soft on you behind when you drink
wine you're such a [ __ ] you think you're
smart no you're not I couldn't think of
anything that [ __ ] rhymes because I'm
a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah with velvet balls
stuff velvet ball stuff stuff velvet
stuff up against my balls me undies
everybody elevate your underwear game to
the next level with me undies you've
perfected your wardrobe but what about
this stuff not everybody gets to see if
you've been settling for store-bought
underwear five packs I have something
that will change your life for the
better me undies what's the first thing
you put on the last thing you take off
huh that's right your underwear make
your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me and ease
sometimes it's your t-shirt though right
you know you just [ __ ] grab your
sweatpants and your undies you just take
them off and you stay in there with
t-shirt you know and your [ __ ] socks
on
you get the shower going your wife walks
in she starts laughing at you you know
you never did that follow-up what is me
undies
oh just seriously soft feel good undies
delivered right to your [ __ ] door I
want to meet that guy what do you do I
die I bring I deliver underwear to men
you know just always no got along with
people takes a special personality of
shut up bill me undies are designed in
LA and was at Los Angeles Louisiana we
don't know it made from sustainably
sourced micro mode al modal a fabric 3
times softer than cotton my undies
softer than soft luxury undies come in
and ever-changing selection of classic
colors bold shades bold shades right
around their shaft at your dick and
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style
you want a giraffe next to you nuts how
about a sunflower guess what this is
what they do you can save time and money
each month with a monthly subscription
and if you're not ready for a
subscription that's okay you can still
say that's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair just use our
special URL me undies dot-com / / and
get 20% off your first pair so go ahead
revamp your underwear drawer you deserve
it I throw out those shit-stained those
skid knocked undies huh
once again that's my undies dot-com / /
me undies dot-com / / how many more
these [ __ ] things I got to read two
more you want me to read these two now
you want to hear the story about me
trying to make [ __ ] dumplings let's
talk about that hey we're any any [ __ ]
Asians out there any Asians listen to
this podcast anybody from the five East
migrated over here maybe a
second-generation
or maybe your family's like old-school
and they kept the tradition going so you
know how to make [ __ ] dumplings i i
love dumplings alright i'm like Oprah
right now I love doglegs I [ __ ] love
dumplings and I told you the story of
when I was in Singapore and I was on my
way to Hong Kong and I was in the
[ __ ] airport lounge and
can't eat all the [ __ ] dumplings I
swear to god I don't know how his belly
wasn't hanging over his pants he's a
little skinny [ __ ] was like as a
competitive eater they kept bringing him
out in like in like groups are like 14
and this [ __ ] guy would eat like 11
of them it's like he was flying around
the world and there was gonna be no food
in the goddamn plane so the best
dumplings I have a [ __ ] head I was in
Hong Kong I went to some dim sum [ __ ] I
don't know what the hell it was but it
is a [ __ ] art form over there but
I'll tell you here in America they still
do a great job but the dumplings the
pots I love him
all right I told you guys a while ago I
was you know I want to get outside my
palette and I never cooked with any of
the Asian [ __ ] even though I love it
right so I decided that I'm going to try
to make these [ __ ] dumplings right so
of course I don't have any of the
ingredients I need other than the flour
hot water sugar salt what are the [ __ ]
else did I have and of course I had some
of that with a soy sauce I had that but
everything else I didn't have I don't
have anything else so I go to the white
grocery store right I go to their little
Asian section that's right next to the
Mexican section that's a little bit
bigger and then everything else is just
for Northern Europeans I mean that's
that's a white grocery store that's what
it's like okay so I say to the guy you
got his [ __ ] chili sauce do you have
any of the dark soy sauce and you know I
actually asked an Asian dude that worked
at the fish counter and he was like nah
nah man they don't have that [ __ ] here
and I was like do you know where I can
get it it was like no I mean I don't
know what you live in I was like all
right sorry so I ended up going to uh
whatever was a Koreatown
titin I don't what the [ __ ] was I went
and I went to into this grocery store
and I come walking whole new [ __ ]
world
all these [ __ ] noodles all of this
[ __ ] I'm looking at going that's the
stuff when I order there it is right
there right so I'm looking for my sty
needed like corn flour and they didn't
have any so when I went to the Thai
grocery store I was looking for it and
there was this Asian lady there with
their mother and she sees me the [ __ ]
white dude
round-eye here looking at the [ __ ]
trying to figure stuff out she starts
laughing she goes what are you trying to
make and then I laughed I said am i
trying to make dumplings she goes
alright what do you need I said I'm
trying to find cornflour she goes oh you
know just you know since she talks to
her mother without are they [ __ ] you
know it's the real deal [ __ ] you know
bilingual [ __ ] going down and they're
trying to help me find the cornflour
they couldn't so I they found this other
[ __ ] and that was close to it like I
don't thinking use that so I was like a
[ __ ] maybe I got to go to Chinatown I
have no [ __ ] idea so I thanked him
and they say good luck and I leave then
I'm standing up at the register and was
hilarious that same woman came up to me
and this is what she says to me this
like a minute later she goes excuse me
she goes will you the guy was just
talking to and immediately I'm like oh
my god we all look alike to him
so I laugh and I go yet she goes I just
googled it you can use this as a
substitute she took the time out to
Google I was like you know what you
you're awesome
she said no worries I said alright see
you later so now I got a new grocery
store to go to so I come home so I go to
the meat store I get my [ __ ] pork and
all that [ __ ] again my ginger right all
this [ __ ] that I'm gonna put in there so
I go to make this making the filling was
[ __ ] easy but bok choy
[ __ ] cutting up the green onions all
of that it's smelling right it's looking
right everything's going good then I go
to do the [ __ ] dough and god damnit
that was a [ __ ] not mixing it up
mixing it up was easy but like just
trying to make him into a round circle
was uh that was not easy forget about
folding them up and so whatever I put a
little oil in the pan it took me forever
took me like two hours to do this whole
thing and I was talking to somebody else
who married into an Asian family it was
just like oh man he goes when they do it
they they [ __ ] how quickly you know
they can [ __ ] get the dumpling
together and fold it up and make it look
right it's like it's like a [ __ ] it's
like magic you know and I'm sitting
there all clumsy trying to get the thing
together and it took me like two hours
to get the whole thing together and for
whatever reason this [ __ ] recipe I
had like how many I have I had like
[ __ ] four
40 of them almost like I almost quit
like 15 times just going like it how
many times can I have ordered dumplings
from the people that invented them that
know what the [ __ ] they're doing but I
plowed ahead right so we get the oil in
the pan and I just follow the thing you
know when they get nice and golden brown
then you pour your water in you put the
lid on him you steam him when the waters
gone they're done and I got to tell you
they were they were ugly on a scale of
one to ten they were a strong six did
not look good too many different sizes
even though the ladies on the on the
video showed me how to do it I still
[ __ ] that up and um and then you know
I'm the worst I have to stop [ __ ]
doing this cuz I always go to knee like
was it good how does it taste
is it good in the second she knows I
want approval she turns into [ __ ]
Simon Cowell he was just saying yeah I
know there are you know it's like I even
say it looks and I know these aren't
great for a first attempt is that's
pretty good right I look you know
insecure [ __ ] guy that I am I need a
look just give me a little [ __ ]
feedback comedian that's why I like
stand-up hunt you guys like it ha ha ha
we like to dead silence alright I get it
alright how about this one now do you
like me do you like me again
you know that's how I live my life I
live moment to [ __ ] moment not in a
Zen way just in a completely insecure
way right so she's not giving it up and
I go so we know what's what's what's up
she goes there's something uh I don't
know the dough is just not you know
she's clearly just opening them up and
just eating the middle out of them I go
to two like sticky she just no that's
not the word um and immediately I'm just
like oh god I just want to [ __ ] just
yeah
Oh gummy is that to work out yeah sticky
gummy you want to Saurus how do you say
the [ __ ] word so this is what
happened is you know I learned from the
chef that you got to be you know tasting
your food I forever I used to cook and I
wouldn't be tasting so I was tasting the
whole [ __ ] way and
the chef told me you know by the time
it's done you're not gonna want any
because you've tasted so much of it so
I'd already had so many [ __ ]
dumplings the time I got it like I was
almost a little sick and I [ __ ] ate
him and I knew that they weren't right
but I definitely had a good time I think
I would quarter that recipe so I only
make like [ __ ] eight of them then I
could have fun and I could actually like
take my time rather than do it was like
I swear to god it was so perfect that I
did it during tax time because that's
what it felt like you know when you got
all your receipts all laid out and all
these little balls of [ __ ] flour but
um doing this morning like I didn't even
clean up I went downstairs and I was
just like a dumplings and I had a
[ __ ] scotch I was doing so well on my
diet next day I [ __ ] woke up with
like a starving child with it like a
distended belly you know if that
starving child was an alcoholic and it's
like [ __ ] him I came upstairs and just
the smell of that [ __ ] soy sauce and
all that [ __ ] after all those dumplings
I [ __ ] ate and I swear to God I
actually have a newfound respect for
that son of a [ __ ] they dumped those
dumplings in in Singapore I don't know
what the [ __ ] that guy's stomach is made
out of a dude you can't eat all of that
dough so then of course eaten like that
kind of threw me off my diet went to
this [ __ ] great cookout today and I
you know I ate well but not well if you
know what I mean so who knows whatever
I'm doing well don't want with the diet
so I'm still going in the right
direction
okay I've shaved off about eight pounds
out for the [ __ ] Christmas ham here
Oh Billy's gonna be able to fit in suits
in about another five pounds get down
like 170 171 that's it
then I'm gonna try on that suit again
you know why cuz I'm not a quitter all
right
I hung in there with the dumplings but
I'm not gonna [ __ ] go down to I'm not
going I'm not gonna be that guy I told
you guys that I'm not gonna be the guy
that goes down to the dry cleaners and
has his [ __ ] suits let out sitting
there with your [ __ ] shoulders
slumped alright and if you're if you're
in that right now if you're doing that
right now you got to keep one [ __ ]
suit okay that you don't do that to and
I would make it your favorite [ __ ]
suit
when you look the best in that's it
you have your fat suits you're literally
wearing a fat suit like [ __ ] Eddie
Murphy in the Klumps except when they
say cut you know in the end of the day
they can't remove it what are you doing
get on a [ __ ] treadmill all right
Dollar Shave Club everybody buying a
razor it's a lot like buying a car
except it's yes wait wait cheaper to get
smooth larger luxury quality you have to
pay a huge price and that means you're
paying mostly for splashy marketing and
features you don't actually need switch
to Dollar Shave Club it's the smart
choice luxury quality at an economy
price Dollar Shave club's razors are
amazing quality they've got the shave
technology you need and none of that
overpriced gimmicky [ __ ] you don't have
you seen the ad for the razors
monopolies newest razor thing it's like
a 24 blade swivel pivot robot razor with
the laser pointer every year they make a
tiny change of the rate tiny change to
the razor and then try to convince you
it's totally new and you need to spend
even more for it and then the new blades
don't fit your old [ __ ] handle all
that Steve Jobs [ __ ] join Dollar Shave
Club and be done with all of that
there's never been a better time to give
them a shot right now you can get the
first month of their amazing razors for
only a buck including free shipping and
after that it's just a few bucks a month
there's no long term commitments relax
no hidden fees you can cancel whenever
you want get your first month for just a
buck at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / one more read oh
and it's nice and quick stamps.com these
people get it man that got a nice quick
copy I use stamps comb to send out any
of my posters anytime or myself uh after
my shows if I can figure it out so can
you stamps saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
or just sit there and stare at the wall
drinking your favorite bourbon I can
mail any letter any package using my
computer and my printer and the mailman
comes by and picks it up avoid the
hassle man to go into the post office
and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages domestic or
international stamps com will even help
you decide the best class of mail based
on your needs no need to lease an
expensive postage meter right now here
we go the big fun
you can enjoy the stamps service with a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
without a long-term commitment go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bur
that stamps calm and tuber stamps calm
never go to the post office again unless
you're one of those weirdos that collect
stamps alright let's get to some of the
some of the [ __ ] questions here for
the week shall we shall we um
the lovely need everybody is my food
here it's been here what did I order
again yes everybody knows I was talking
to you about your your your cold
calculated review of my dumplings you
know how you do hey sweetie
what's up buddy you just woke up look at
that smile
what oh you know what I'm biased but we
got we got one cute ass kid up just yeah
you're dumping you you you you you made
dumplings see this is what I'm talking
about it's so cold yes you you you you
you made dumplings right I mean you know
you made it I don't mean you tried you
did make it
no you can't this is this is you can't
you can't give it up ever
I look up hard this is for you give it
up you know I feel like I'm very honest
with you is what it is because I respect
you so oh you're gonna turn this around
that was a nice little flippy Duty you
did there because I respect you I'm
gonna be honest with you if I didn't
respect to you I would just be like oh
yeah everything you do is amazing well
good didn't come out right either
what I'm trying to say is I think that
you put forth a great effort I'm just
going to keep talking your way down this
[ __ ] well I'm done I'm done
yeah okay well you know what I realize I
respect you too that means I'm going to
start being as honest as you are that's
what I'm going to do exactly that you're
upset with me about because you can't
just be like you know that they're all
right they're not great that would be
perfect but you have to be like um
there's something with the dough and I
was just like is it sticky you're like
it's not the word oh just let me just
put two behind my ear and I'll move on
to the next [ __ ] meal then you have
to finally just be like I'm gummy is
that the word that's what and then you
said what gummy means usually like blow
bubbles with it and I just couldn't even
say anything because if I said anything
I would start laughing because obviously
I don't mean that you can blow bubbles
with it I know you just you're you're a
tough you're a tough one you're a tough
one it's it's tough to get a compliment
out of you know like dumplings are oh so
easy to make you know what I mean it was
your first try they looked amazing the
filling was good just the dough part was
yeah dough part was do is definitely off
I think I like overcooked it I think I'm
not sure but I'm not I'm just saying you
have like you have this dislike you just
take out the sickle when it's when it's
coming you turn it like an Olympic judge
to be like you could be like yet I mean
not the best but you know you'll get
them on the next one give me a little
pat on the [ __ ] head you're just like
nope these are not good have a nice
evening I will see you in the morning
all right I'll take this opportunity you
won't I've been talking about this for
[ __ ] 14 years hey buddy
Oh can I take a bite out of this aha
huh why can't you say this age forever
just be this big big ball of cute we
carry around huh she's got a mischievous
look on her face
huh you gonna be puffy tonight like last
night yeah
yeah I'll tell you it was a rough one
all right let me finish this up here so
I can wait my cold fish or chicken or
whatever I ordered chicken all right no
I'm not and you're way off the mic we're
probably been annoying the [ __ ] out of
people for the last five minutes okay
all right hey Mia that that dress is I
mean it's a dress you're you're wearing
it and I still I can't even do it to you
you look great [ __ ] get out of here
all right wagon please read please read
hey there Billy baby white it's the
first kid one all right I heard the
email you read a couple weeks ago about
the older guy who was wondering if it
was worth it to lay off the booze and
reconnect with his family I can tell you
I wasn't as bad as that guy but it made
me realize I could be a better person
I quit boozing two days after I heard
his story I called my brother and I
started a dialogue I should have started
eight years ago I used to listen you
talk about booze and think it was an
excuse to keep boozing not placing the
blame on you I'm a [ __ ] well yeah I
mean I don't know you so I wouldn't
think that you were trying to blame me I
wouldn't accept the blame either but
then I realized you don't drink all day
every day and that you have a full
career and a kid and a wife I have a
plumbing and heating job and a terrier I
still smoke weed because it helps with
my arthritis which is actually very
severe and prevents me from doing things
just picturing you jerking off god damn
it I can't
I can't sustain it prevents me from
doing things like running and lifting
comfortably the call to my brother
initiated well I bet taking all that
booze out of your system will probably
help out I don't think boozing is good
for your joints is it all that sugar I
don't I don't I was just repeat [ __ ]
that I have listened to I'm sorry the
call my brother initiated his inviting
me to Eastern ice the first holiday I
will spend with my family in almost nine
years thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all
right
well I don't know what you thanking me
for and you did I don't know that I said
anything
by the way my wife was watching dr. Phil
and they had this [ __ ] guy on there
it was one of the most [ __ ] up things
I've ever seen on TV this guy was
basically going on the internet
he was into conspiracy theory and he
lost his job and he went got into this
meditating thing and he said he had
reached this spiritual plane of constant
meditation and nobody and he couldn't
explain it to anybody around him like
his wife and dr. Phil's trying to talk
to the guy and he goes he just kept
going like so what are you trying you're
you're meditating you're on the internet
you're meditating and and then the guy
just kept taking this arrogant like line
with him going yes see once again I mean
you'd have to read up I mean I can't
just explain this to you I can send you
links on to try to get to my level
basically of higher thinking and then
dr. Phil's like don't talk down to me
okay first of all you don't know me I'm
one of the most open-minded people
you're ever going to meet first of all
who the [ __ ] says that about themselves
I'm one of the greatest people I've ever
met right it's a long story short they
bring in Deepak Chopra all right another
[ __ ] of spirituality you know what he's
a [ __ ] of psychology and this [ __ ]
jerk-off comes in with these [ __ ]
bright red sneakers on it sits down next
to this guy the guy's freaking out
because he feels like he's on the same
plane as this guy and then he
to basically say that this guy is a
banning his family he picked his words
carefully I will say that about Oh
[ __ ] Deepak Dee to the mother [ __ ]
Chopra he basically picked his words
carefully but in the end he said to dr.
Phil that he feels this guy is bipolar
this [ __ ] poor bastard found out that
he was bipolar on national television
like oh and the guy [ __ ] sister
excellent he's helping people basically
you're bipolar you're not reaching a
higher spiritual plane as much as you
are experiencing a manic episode yeah
I'm just doing that Judge Judy [ __ ]
where he's talking all tough - this I -
two minutes into it I was like this guy
needs some serious psychological help
and I I don't I don't know [ __ ] [ __ ]
Deepak coming out with making this face
I'm trying to think who the [ __ ] he
looks like I don't know what he looks
like Liberace whatever whatever
nationale what is he is the Indian he's
like if India had a Liberace business
but they ever do the [ __ ] Michael
Douglas Matt Damon version of Liberace
if they do it in some Bollywood think
that you got it you got a cast that guy
I love that he was just available - does
he live out in Hollywood alright anyways
I have no [ __ ] idea I don't know
anymore
you know my favorite things - is my wife
is on Instagram and Instagram is a pain
in the ass because if you're not on it
you can't look at the photos and [ __ ]
and I just can't join another social
media site but one of my favorite
[ __ ] things are those people who take
up pictures of themselves in their
amazing bodies after they workout and
rather theirs in saying don't I look
[ __ ] amazing they actually act like
they're trying to motivate you you know
like reach hashtag reach your goals
[Laughter]
um hashtag putting that work in um I
don't I think I'm just I've just become
an old man now and I don't understand
younger people I just don't understand
like it did the level of douche chills
that you would take a picture of
yourself while you're working out you
know under the guise that you're trying
to motivate people you know like this
isn't about me guys this is in my
eight-pack this is about you I'm trying
to I try to inspire people with my
beauty that's why I don't believe in
Christ when I just see moments like that
it's just like what is God waiting for
when are you going to send this dude
back like how bad does it have to get
you know in a way I almost blame God at
this point it's like you're enabling us
how long are you going to keep letting
us have the intelligence to invent these
devices to further disappear up our own
[ __ ] as I said in a podcast talking
to myself for a [ __ ] hour oh Jesus I
swear to God every time I think I'm
making a point I just realized what a
[ __ ] hypocrite I am all right little
girl statue in Syria okay this sounds
like clickbait you know when you see
little girl finds a statue in Syria what
she does next will shock you and you
know you click on it and there's one
photo and eighty-seven ads [ __ ] all of
those sites all right bill for days
people flooded Facebook and praise of
the little girl statue they placed in
front of the Wall Street bull everybody
mostly women and social justice warriors
went on about resisting and how powerful
the statue was I choose to fight it
turns out the little girl statute was
put up by a media / marketing company
that has zero interest in doing anything
but creating a buzz for themselves
that's not that's not all the bullets
was a piece of art erected by an
independent artist it was panned by Wall
Street and they wanted it removed
the people kept it there everyone is a
sucker
whatever that means kony2012 I cited a
source below unless the rest of the
[ __ ] on Facebook thank you skip some
words here sorry for the stomach
growling also that white hat document
mentary that went everywhere about the
group of volunteers that came to the aid
of Syrian chemical weapons victims was
part of a huge agenda to make America
mad at the Syrian regime international
reporters are questioning the source of
those weapons some think it was even it
wasn't even the Syrian government we're
all [ __ ] love you love me and congrats
on the little lady um yeah I believe all
that type of [ __ ] I believe that type of
[ __ ] I don't know buddy that type of
stuff but I definitely believe that they
they show images to make us [ __ ]
upset about stuff you know seems very
easy to defeat terrorism to me all you
do is just embrace the electric cars
just make everything electric we stopped
buying oil from those guys they don't
have any money they go bankrupt and next
thing you know they can't afford
anything but rocks we're not over there
they gradually forget about us they go
back to arguing with one another we just
slowly back away why don't we just do
that you know why because there's no
money in that that's what I think but
what do I know
alright terrified of a threesome can I
can I click on this link up here what is
this link this person sent me I don't
know why oh I know why because I don't
have it I got a click on it when it's in
the email what's in the one it's an
email now how do I find what the [ __ ]
email is live reads boom I go to that
click on inbox retrace all my steps go
to the content scroll down click on the
link wait for it to open it is now
trying to load alright I'll get back to
that a minute in the meantime terrified
of a threesome
hey parenthesis insert cheap redhead
insult here huge fan love you stand up
an eptas for family thank you I'm 20 I'm
a 21 year old college student who has a
girlfriend that is bisexual and
beautiful as well god bless you whoa god
bless you sir god bless you
there's no way you don't believe in God
man god bless you
we've talked about asking girls to join
us in bed and are finally getting ready
to have it happen the girl that's
joining us is a girl that the both of us
have gotten with in the past at
different times ah this is perfect the
only problem is that I get freaked the
[ __ ] out what I think about this
happening both of the women involved are
hot and experience which is what scares
me
I'm not that astounding looking of a guy
not that well-endowed as far as my dick
goes and not experienced at all Capay
you're going to talk yourself out of
this dude and not experienced at all
compared to these girls how do I get
past my fears and relax enough to make
to be into what's happening and make
sure I make it worthwhile for both these
ladies Thanks and go [ __ ] yourself ah
dude do not [ __ ] this up okay the only
way you can [ __ ] this up is to not show
up just show up and let nature take over
okay it's all right to be freaked out
you're 21 years old you got to [ __ ]
smoking hot chicks want to [ __ ] bang
at the same time that's a lot that's
Rockstar [ __ ] I don't know what you do
for a living but I'm guessing you're not
a [ __ ] rock star so yet this is uh
this is this is [ __ ] great
this is a great goddamn thing you know
and if you want to I just tell your
girlfriend just be like yeah I'm excited
animal gotta be launched I'm a little
nervous you guys are both so but just
keep paying about because it's so
beautiful now things should be don't
wear relax just follow my lead just do
that just be open and honest about it
but don't take it to the [ __ ] point
do you like don't say all that other
[ __ ] you know I'm not a good guy
they could have had a bigger dick then
she's gonna think well what the [ __ ] am
I doing this with you for don't go that
far all right here's the thing dude
you're definitely good-looking enough
you definitely got a big enough dick or
none of this [ __ ] would be happening
right okay you got called up to the show
okay get up to the plate and swing out
of your [ __ ] cleats I would let them
start let them start and then you just
kind of [ __ ] you know work your way
in that's all just start making out with
both of them that's it get some [ __ ]
I don't know I don't just just please
please do please for the some day 48
year old you who probably doing a
podcast by himself okay please don't
[ __ ] this up okay don't do not talk
yourself out of this you're getting in
your [ __ ] head
all right you've already gotten with
both of them she obviously likes you
dick she's coming back for more your
girlfriend still there this is just like
this is something else dude and this is
a great experience for you to push past
all that [ __ ] low self-esteem
all right so man the [ __ ] up have a
great time follow up email please all
right my girl loves me too much oh but I
can't love myself at all all right hey
Billy moose knuckle
I always forget what that is I know what
a camel toe is I don't know what a moose
knuckle is I'm a 22 is that a Canadian
camel toe
I don't know I'm a 22 year old college
student and I've been with my girlfriend
for about a year now things have been
great only problem is that she's got the
tendency to tell me I love you or you're
so important to me or I adore you at
least 15 times a day without any lead-up
oh yeah that's creepy she just does it
out of the boo I guess it's nice to hear
but after a point it makes me wonder if
she has some underlying issue I'm the
first boyfriend and she's still shocked
even after dating for a year that
someone finds her attractive
so I hiccups are coming on top of all
this she gets weird and passive
aggressive when I suggest I have a night
to myself saying things like I guess
I'll stay
home alone or I'll just eat leftover
soup and watch the Food Network this
[ __ ] kills me and I usually cave and
come over I'm an introverted heart and
need my time alone to recharge and study
or read my favorite books when we're
together we mostly watch movies talk
about school or [ __ ] which is fine but I
need to be alone once in a while I have
too much empathy and I'm a pushover
which doesn't help anything and it
doesn't help anything I need some advice
do you think she has an attachment
problem or is it something else thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself I would just work
on your end of it whatever her issue is
it might come to a head when you just
say listen I just need a long time
sometimes you know and let her pout and
do whatever the [ __ ] she wants to do and
eventually she'll accept that about you
or she'll tell you why she's too
insecure to not spend the night and you
know spend a night alone or she'll flip
the [ __ ] out and you'll be like wow I'm
not with the right person but I can tell
you this not doing what you want to do
in a relationship is the quickest way to
poison the water okay and I don't mean
just going out and [ __ ] around and
doing all [ __ ] like that but I mean like
you know if you don't like going to
brunch you have to tell them you don't
like going to brunch now you still have
to go to some brunches but you're not
going to be going to them all the time
all right to not tell her that you're an
introverted heart and you need your time
alone to recharge and study and all that
type of [ __ ] read your favorite books
you know she has to respect that about
you and you got to respect that about
you okay stop giving into what the [ __ ]
she wants what you you having a night
alone every once in a while is not a
crazy request okay and I would do that
first and see how she reacts and you
might get to the bottom of why she has
to say I love you and I adore you when
all that [ __ ] fifty times a [ __ ] day
probably because you're she's probably
terrified that it's not going to end
well you know she's if she's never had
another boyfriend I'm guessing she's
around your age maybe that gave her some
sort of complex I don't [ __ ] know
this is something few guys to work out
but I got to tell you this right now if
you need a long time you got to tell her
that or else you're going to end up
resenting her and the whole relationship
is going to gradually
our it's [ __ ] downward spiral and
that's it and it crashes and burns right
in a [ __ ] cornfield okay that's it
that's the podcast for this week is
everything that I wanted to talk about I
got Boise Idaho coming up this weekend
yes next weekend I'll be out there with
rose bowl tailgate legend and puck off
host all things comedy network podcaster
Joe bartnick we're going to have a great
time on our up there that is all go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday